hello and welcome to this video playing
kill the yarn here what's a meth and the
other i have always have sloth defense
against them so i'm going to play some
london system that's Carlo de Moura
every frequent opponent 37th game the
38th game janam I simply don't get back
to 2400m bed run should g4 Wow
it looks very provocative just develop
the bishop and combine that with some
weird Queens gambit accepted it looks
really really wacky okay is there some
technique that I'm missing I don't think
so i can just take this right so let's
develop h4 is an interesting move in
this kind of position he wants to go if
I've here right okay
okay let's let's let's do this
threatening G for winning a piece hmm d
5 is now the sharpest movement this is
also going to be somewhat risky
hmm surprising so h5 is not it's not
afraid of that okay g4 it's got age five
okay okay let's get get out of this
temple for the moment
is he always plays the most ambitious
move whatever if it's good or not it
just gets played and maybe it's also
just the right warfare I'm not saying it
isn't but it's always super ambitious
it's never ever small okay how do you
cover seven probably you don't write
okay the main idea of d5 is to open up
the C file okay I can take here on c6
first huh maybe but ok well I can
actually take and then play the bishop
bag ask him about his his queen this one
threatening night a foreign things like
that looks pretty bad I think you and
I'll do this first before I do anything
else I'll go for the pin now this ok so
who I can trade and be a pawn up but it
doesn't look like the best possible way
to play really not every night a fall or
something
and now I can be for us is that good and
it's tried
when it is night see won't be three and
I take those pawns yeah am I taking or
not that's an interesting question i can
actually also go back but it doesn't
doesn't seem bad it might be slow what
I'm doing in might be too slow night a
c5 coming that was the idea of the setup
let me 1960 em now if I was hanging at a
seminar saying check chicks and before
nor should be five Bishop 85 is the most
materialistic movement when do I have
something better takes
can come on let's go for materialistic
check looks slightly wrong to be honest
fattening Bishop c7 mate and I'm kind of
class how he prevents it okay three is
good shaken but it's just one check and
not if I has made as I yes that's no
defense so I'm happy to get that win in
that that weird opening really was very
provocative ok so I think just Bishop
before and then taking as very Vienna it
just gives me gives me the center and I
really didn't see the point okay I just
developed and this is trying to turn to
win this with this bishops oh ok could
we be three wins wow wow yeah I've
thought about the move but I was
thinking well I think could be five but
now that I think of it h5 is probably
right huh yes this is very strong
actually now very strong
I'm attacking the rook and attacking the
bishop so and it doesn't have root be
eight because my bishop is on that so
this is the best and then I take end
just win that's nice so queen bee three
years refutation of the black seller
well this is not so powerful it h five
or ten to age five well you know but i
forgot that i can take care wow I'm just
very very stupid I was thinking here and
I take and he takes h5 of course I can
just do this and I'm winning yeah this
is what I mean I placed some ambitious
stuff that often does not work but I
really often just don't see the
refutation this winds and this is all so
edgy takes is actually already enough so
that was already end of game but I
didn't see it but I saw that one which
also wins and maybe d5 wasn't the best I
don't know a computer actually dislike
center and things just this and wins
yeah maybe I wanted to open the sea fowl
it the engine says I can he can't it can
take and play here and oh wow well it's
a whole mess while it would have been
very awkward but you didn't do it plate
like this and now everything is kind of
okay again yeah Chang oops
yeah I didn't like that push away five
so much but I just wanted to keep the
pawn and make it play easy rules the
engine has to take and do this is also
looks very good just winning this one
check check but this it should it should
win I can i get the night over here and
here we are talking about the first mate
at the engine gives jen86 funny ok well
there was a bit at least thanks for
watching